Sometimes when you grow up, you don't quite realize
how all the  experiences you have
shape who you become down the road.
And it's been very interesting in this role to look back and think about how my views
on diversity and inclusion have been
shaped by my own experiences throughout my life.
And I'd like to maybe call out two of those.
One is being a first generation student
and the other being an immigrant.
I, as you can tell, clearly have an accent and
I didn't move to the United States
until I was just about 30 years old.
And it took me a while to figure out that no matter
how hard I tried to blend in,
I will always stand out.
And at some point in time that was very confusing.
And then I realized you know,
it's actually something interesting.
It's a great way to sort of connect and actually start
talking about diversity and inclusion.
And one of the ways at a place like Emory
in which it has really helped me is we're a global university.
We have people from all over the world and
includes our faculty, students and staff.
It also has helped me understand, particularly in the last
year or so, how difficult it has been as U.S. society
is contemplating about what is the role of immigrants.
And as we know, it's quite polarized.
There are those who believe that without immigrants,
the United States never would be what it would be,
but that enough is enough
and we need to stop immigration.
And then there are people who see that,
but say that we need to keep this going because this is
why we are this incredible society that we are.
That's why we have the impact on the world that we have.
So you find yourself as an immigrant between those two
groups and try to figure out well,
what does it mean for me?
And especially for our students, it has been very difficult.
Because these are people that came to the United States,
they want to have a U.S. Education.
They believe that's the best education they can have.
That it provides the best experience
they can have to survive.
But at the same time, they experience fear
because you no longer know if you're welcome.
Sometimes you don't want to acknowledge
that you are an immigrant.
At the same time we have students
who are not immigrants,
but who look like immigrants or who sound like immigrants
who get very upset when people start labeling them as immigrants.
So it has opened the door to really talk about what does diversity mean,
what does inclusion mean.
And what we have all realized and we are very committed to
addressing is the notion that you can have all the diversity in the world,
but it doesn't create a positive culture.
And in order to have a positive culture, you must have a focus
on inclusion so that everybody feels part of it,
everybody feels respected.
And I think it's that respect that is so important to people.
Even if we don't understand the differences between the cultures,
even if there are barriers, as long as there is respect
and dignity, people are okay with it.
So we have a lot of formal and informal activities to address that.
I also notice that it almost seems that the more diverse
an institution gets, in my case,
talking about Emory, the more diverse Emory gets,
the more difficult inclusion, in some ways, becomes.
Because people try to sometimes pull back into groups that
are inclusive and that are the groups that you align with the most.
And a lot of people will say well, we're inclusive because you're here,
so why do I need to do extra work to make you feel welcome?
But all of those are wonderful lessons and that's
what universities like Emory stand for.
So I do believe that because I am an immigrant,
it really has helped me be a voice in that conversation
and ask some of the questions that maybe I couldn't ask
had it not been for the fact that I am an immigrant.